je le dis et je les crises et
m'encourager moi ce qui me gêne pas je
vous encourage à ce qui me gêne c'est
que ces règles ne soient pas adaptées et
démocratiquement conçu et respecter
c'est ça qui me gêne c'est les règles à
géométrie variable
mais toute construction commune suppose
l'adhésion à un minimum de six sinon ça
n'est rien sinon faut pas faire l'europe
et bien vous gêne pas alors ça dépend
aussi que quand vous me dites attention
derrière ce texte là proprement dit il y
a une volonté de discrimination là ça me
gêne
bien sûr mais pour le reste moi il me
semble que l'école pour reprendre son
sang ce cas là devrait être dans une
forme de neutralité et moi je préfère
effectivement que ce soit les parents
qui assurent l'éducation intime sexuelle
de leurs enfants il me semble plus que
plus que l'école mais c'est un point de
vue je vous propose de passer à un autre
sujet qui n'a vraiment rien à voir on va
parler de ce qu'on appelle des mobilités
douces
alors peut-être par antiphrase enfin ça
c'est la novlangue les mobilités douces
et les vélos les trottinettes
électriques et il se trouve que il ya eu
un drame il ya quelques jours c'était le
14 juin
une jeune femme prénommée miriam a été
tué par deux personnes deux jeunes
femmes qui étaient temps sur une
trottinette électrique qui ont pris la
fuite mais qui ont été arrêtés depuis
les piétons de paris savent qu'il faudra
très attention maintenant quand on se
déplace pas ce qu'est les trottinettes
il ya les vélos qui ne respectent pas
forcément ni les feux rouges ni les sens
interdits bref sont ils dangereux ces
moyens de mobilité douce
écoutez d'abord pour la défense
des deux roues la vie de fabrice fut
relancé le président de la fédération
professionnelle de la micro mobilité
pour lui ce sont pas ces moyens de
transport qu'ils sont dangereux c'est
juste quelques irresponsables
les mauvais comportements sont toujours
une minorité mais qui est voilà qui
pourrissent la majorité brice la
majorité est aujourd'hui une
réglementation qui est en place qui est
très clair qui est dans le code de la
route et qui interdit sur trottoir qui
interdit l'usagé à 2 qui oblige en
assurance et c'est cette réglementation
qu'il faut faire respecter et qui ne
l'est pas parce qu'il faut sanctionner
il écrit richard briques vous êtes un
élu parisien je le rappeler en début
d'émission c'est un c'est un vrai sujet
pour pour un adjoint au maire du 2e
arrondissement comme vous
oui parce que les trottinettes c'est un
vrai sujet pour de nombreux habitants de
mon arrondissement et pendant les
campagnes électorales et aujourd'hui
encore quand je rencontre des habitants
beaucoup interroge sur la mise en oeuvre
des réglementations qui sont prévus sur
la circulation des trottinettes
électriques parce qu'elles vont aux hits
parce que parfois elles sont sur les
trottoirs là où ils ne font pas et parce
que en gros elles sont c'est vrai ce que
dit le représentant
on a entendu il ya des comportements qui
sont pas du tout adaptés sur ce type
d'engin donc sur le fait que si on les
entend pas parce qu'elles font pas mais
sur le fait qu'il ya un problème
oui et qu'on essaie de le réguler oui et
que ça a commencé avec des décisions qui
ont été prises au niveau du conseil de
paris pour interdire leur circulation
sur certains enfin sur les trottoirs
pour essayer de réguler le fait qu'elle
soit garée un peu n'importe où et donc
de créer des stationnements spécialement
dédiée maintenant quand on a dit ça est
à la fois des mobilités douces qui sont
dangereuses dans le cas que vous évoquez
de la personne qui a était c'est un
frappe et on va dire bousculé par deux
personnes qui étaient sur une
trottinette et qui a fini à l'hôpital et
qui est décédé voilà personne qu ont
pris la fuite et s'est donc on voit bien
qu'il ya à la fois un effet de la
trottinette mais aussi des personnes et
de leur comportement
il y avait eu aussi à nîmes il ya
quelques temps une personne en
trottinette qui s'était fait percuter
par une voiture et qui a été décédé il y
avait eu aussi des scooters qui avait
percuté de manière grave d
des personnes ont entre tine est donc on
voit que c'est un nouveau type
en tout cas de problème qu'il faut qu'on
aborde et que en tant qu'élu local c'est
un vrai sujet en tout cas moi je suis
confronté je le dis aujourd'hui c'est
trottinette principalement les trois
tiens je trouve que le problème des
vélos est différent ça veut pas dire
qu'il ya pas un problème mais le
problème des trottinettes est un peu
spécifique quand elle circule largement
sur les trottoirs et qu'elles font peur
notamment à des personnes qui se
déplacent qu'elle soit avec des enfants
soient des personnes âgées ou donc il ya
un sujet et par ailleurs on le sait
c'est pas nécessairement les engins les
plus écolos du monde il pourrait gagner
à l'être un peu plus mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas leur durée de vie c'est
un mois maximum on dit 28 jours en
général principalement fabriqués en
chine on pourra peut-être aussi veiller
à les fabriquer un peu autrement
donc c'est pas non plus la mobilité
parfaites ya des améliorations des
progrès à faire aussi donc oui c'est
dangereux où il faut réguler et oui il
faut améliorer le service qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas forcément celui
qu'il faut mais je dis très clairement
alors vous nous dites que vélo
tranquille assez pas forcément les mêmes
risques mêmes dangers on va on va en
parler tout de suite mais je donne
d'abord la vie de nos internautes
notre petite question selon vous les
vélos et les trottinettes électriques
sont ils dangereux et vous répondez oui
à 75%
alex rappelle que l'objet en soi n'est
pas dangereux c'est l'usager qui ne sait
pas l'utiliser qu'il est françois
témoigne qu'il a failli se faire
renverser deux fois sur le trottoir par
des vélos qui roulait trop vite
et puis nicole appelé sa mobilité douce
quand on voit le nombre de blessés c'est
un doux euphémisme
et puis ce point de vue de une autre si
les conducteurs de ces véhicules
respecter le code de la route il n'y a
pas de souci je suis devenu trop que
vous qui êtes une parisienne accompli
est ce que vous les trouvez dangereux
tous ces gens ce que les trouve
extrêmement dangereux vous dépassez un
appui à pied à pied et au rétro non je
trouve l'important c'est qu'il ya en
fait il ya il y à vis à la base
miss de fabrication dans le déferlement
des mobilités douces à paris c'est que
vraisemblablement elles ont été conçues
par anne hidalgo comme un voyage
beaucoup sa poule devise blindé par la
france la phrase plusieurs voix quand
même comme un moyen d'investir le
terrain dont il fallait chasser les
voitures à paris et c'est pour ça que
c'est le foot toi et c'est pour ça que
c'est la jeune et c'est pour ça qu'on va
commencer par leur dire allez-y c'est
tout pour vous et qu'on ne va surtout
pas imposer des règles contraignantes
parce que le bon sens aurait voulu qu'on
fasse l'averse qu'on définit d'abord des
règles des espaces qui garantissent la
sécurité des plus vulnérables
c'est-à-dire les piétons quel qu'il soit
quel que soit leur âge d'ailleurs cette
jeune femme qui a été tuée à un site de
sa chute après avoir été percuté elle
avait 35 ans était en parfaite forme
physique 1 il y avait c'était pas
une vieille dame et un enfant donc c'est
une jeune qui a été provoqués à dessein
pour chasser la voiture à ce qu'on peut
réglementer plus durement richard veut
qu'on peut pas mettre un il faudrait
mettre un policier quasiment à chaque
que à chaque croisement moi qui fais la
gueule du vélib
je peux vous dire qu a pas beaucoup de
gens qui s'arrête au feu un parmi les
cyclistes
oui non mais que vous interrogez le
comportement on est d'accord mais je
veux dire prenons un exemple du moment
rencontré comme on l'a fait le
commissaire d'un arrondissement le
procureur ils vous disent quoi qu'en ce
moment on a une explosion des cas
d'incivilité violence et que bien
évidemment les mobilités elles ont aussi
une partie qui concerne ce regain est
cette recrudescence
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il y avait
rien avant mais là concrètement avec le
déconfinement on constate qu'il y à une
recrudescence à la fois des mauvais
comportements des violences dans tous
les domaines et donc on a aussi sur les
utilisations de vélib et de trottinettes
moi je dis quand même que c'est un petit
peu différent la partie vélo et la
partie trottinette parce que la partie
vélo elle était dans c'est quelque chose
qui est dans le code de la route qui
était prévu c'est quelque chose qui
était déjà réglementée et qu'il fallait
probablement amélioré par rapport aux
services tels qu'ils étaient qui n'était
pas forcément pertinent extra les
trottinettes je vous rappelle qu'il y
avait rien un moment elles ont arrêté
investi question je voulais vous poser
la police municipale a le pouvoir de
verbaliser des vélos sur une peau lisse
du quotidien et notamment pour les
incivilités dans les documents de
campagne que j'ai distribué elles ont
notamment à faire de la verbalisation
sur la gestion des gens sur les
trottoirs mais justement parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce ne serait pas honnête
et vélo mais des lots comme transmettre
ces gars là c'est les deux et les vélos
en plus avaient déjà à l'époque un cadre
qui était très définis avec une
un code de la route qui a interdit
qu'elle circule sur les trottoirs alors
après il ya le paradoxe de pistes
cyclables qui se font sur des trottoirs
là à titre personnel je trouve que c'est
justement tout le paradoxe puisque on
demande à ce que ça circule sur la
chaussée et que ce soit considérée comme
véhicule pour quoi les mettre sur les
trottoirs pas ça c'est un vrai sujet
mais en revanche je trouve que sur la
partie trottinette il ya eu quelque
chose qui n'a pas été anticipée et que
notamment
je le dis aussi des entreprises ont
trouvé le biais avec les failles et
elles sont imposés un modèle avant même
qu'on ait anticipé la réalité de ce
modèle et la régulation de ce modèle il
a fallu qu'on régule a posteriori ça
c'est exact mais sur par exemple vélib
on avait beaucoup mieux je trouve
travailler d'abord il ya eu des pistes
cyclables
lula le service il y avait eu une
réflexion sur tout ce qui était la
maintenance tout ce qui était le travail
avec ben voilà aujourd'hui je pense que
les trottinettes on est sur un véritable
autre sujet de ce que l'on en fait et
par ailleurs mais ça c'est l'expert de
la fondation jean jaurès en charge du
sport et société mais au moment où on se
dit que finalement beaucoup nos ados ont
besoin de bouger que on a des problèmes
d'obésité et c'est la facilité de
déplacement court avec les trottinettes
électriques n'est pas non plus un
phénomène qui va avec ses
recommandations en matière de santé pour
de nombreux jeunes donc je trouve qu'il
y a en tout cas un paradoxe dans notre
manière c'est d'évoquer les choses en
toi il en ressort que vous vous n'aimez
pas trop les tracteurs enfin vouloir
fêter largement réussi c'était pas
écologiste est pas c'est dangereux
pareil pour les écologistes c'est pas
assez mais tous les cas ce n'est pas
obligatoire non plus heureusement
d'ailleurs
non mais il ya un vrai il ya un vrai
sujet alors aujourd'hui on a dans les
écoles d apprentissage ont fait dans le
12e qui s'appelle savoir rouler où on
apprend à ses taux aux enfants à pouvoir
vous voulez avec un vélo donc respecter
le code de la route respecter les
piétons
est-ce qu'il faut pas que demain on
introduisent aussi quelque chose qui
sera sa voir trottiner par quatre au
cinéma comoedia
mais en tout cas il ya un sujet qui est
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas une pratique
qui est
compatible notamment avec la circulation
des piétons qui est quand même la
première des mobilités douces
j'ai dit vous qu'être libéral vous
sauriez pas pour interdire les
trottinettes
ou bien ça vous je ne sais pas je vous
pose la question
non je serais pour verbaliser très
sévèrement quand elles sont sur le
trottoir pour le respect des appels je
crois toujours les passages protégés
commencé à passage piétons sans feu
juste avec des evra au sol à ccc violer
quotidiennement par les trottinettes et
les vélos c'est très très dur quand il
ya un passage clouté sans feu de
s'imposer pour traverser non moi je
serais pour sévir pas dernier est ce
qu'on a on a une idée richard briques du
succès que rencontrent ces trottinette
par rapport au vélo c'est très
minoritaire dans l'est dans les
circulations nouvelle à paris nantes en
a pas de statistiques encore c'est très
compliqué il ya eu un grand engouement
je pense que ça s'est un peu calmé avec
l'effet confinement ça peut tout à fait
reprendre dans les voilà dans l'est dans
les mois qui viennent mais ça avait un
petit peu c'était un petit peu tassé on
va dire mais ça ça va oui ça va je pense
reprendre je pense que l'interdire
interdire la trottinette est un non sens
par contre il faut mieux l'encadrer mais
la réguler effectivement la verbaliser
s'il ya beaucoup mais je pense qu'il
faut aussi responsabiliser ceux qui sont
deux qui sont dessus moi je te crois
comme pour le vélo qu'il faut être sur
les actions plus intensive d'éducation
et quand après il n'y a pas de respect
du code de la route au respect même des
piétons ou autres voilà sanctionné
verbaliser moi je suis là sans problème
comme ça voilà en tout cas là mais paris
ne dissuade pas l'usagé trottinette
puisqu'elle a même aménagé des élus des
places de stationnement spécifiques à
mais pour éviter qu'elles voient la fin
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez mais à
une époque on en avait beaucoup plus
qu'aujourd'hui qui traînait n'importe où
sur la rue moi elle devant chez moi je
loge avait toujours les mêmes qui me
laissait en plein milieu il ya une la
création au bout de la rue d'un espace
spécial trottinette cas gas au plus haut
point les automobilistes qui se sont vu
que manger une place de stationnement
mais par contre sur le trottoir j'en ai
plus absolument et
comme il nous arrive parfois dans cette
émission ou dans le figaro magazine être
critique avec la mairie de paris
on reconnaîtra plus comme à parler des
vélib que leur disponibilité a quand
même beaucoup
c'est quand même beaucoup améliorée
depuis plusieurs mois voilà soyons
justes et puis j'ai un dernier message à
vous donner avant la fin de cette
émission dimanche soir dès 19h vous
pourrez nous retrouver en direct sur
figaro live autour de vincent roux avec
charlotte barillon yves thréard votre
serviteur et emmanuel rivière
le sondeur patron de l'institut kantar 7
en direct dimanche soir dès 19h merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
n'oublie pas de faire votre devoir
civique et très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]